[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos experts et ce 17 mai restera
marquée par l'audition du maire de
Saint-Brévin ou Sénat l'élu harcelé par
un collectif d'extrême droite pour avoir
accepté le déplacement d'un centre
d'accueil pour demandeurs d'asile dans
une école de sa ville à raconter la nuit
où il a été victime d'un attentat
criminel
l'engin explosif a été lancé mis entre
mes deux véhicules
bien entendu on pris feu et ça s'est
propagé en fait également à mon domicile
et nous étions bien sûr dans la maison
heureusement nous avons été
réveillé par par les bruits
c'est le 22 mars trois semaines plus
tard Yannick Morez démissionne et il
accuse aujourd'hui le préfet de
Loire-Atlantique d'avoir menti de
l'avoir laissé seul face aux menaces
l'État et le gouvernement ont-ils manqué
à leur devoir de protection que dit
cette violence politique de la santé de
notre démocratie réponse juste après ces
titres et puis pour notre débat de
société je vous propose un retour sur
cette annonce d'IBM il y a deux semaines
le 2 mai le géant américain annonce un
gel des embauches pour prendre le temps
de définir celles et ceux qui pourraient
être remplacés par l'intelligence
artificielle avec l'IA le monde du
travail est au début d'une nouvelle
révolution sera-t-elle bénéfique ou
catastrophique quels sont les métiers
les plus menacés réponse tout à l'heure
mais d'abord on vous raconte la journée
du maire de Saint-Brevin il est reçu à
Matignon par Elisabeth dans cette fin
d'après-midi et il a retracé devant les
sénateurs l'engrenage qu'il l'a poussé à
la démission Jonathan du priez et Marion
Delpech
point par point le maire démissionnaires
de Saint-Brevin retrace la chronologie
d'un engrenage devant les sénateurs du
projet de déménagement d'un centre pour
migrants près d'une école de sa commune
à l'incendie criminel de son domicile
pour Yannick Morez l'État a failli dès
le début de ce projet controversé l'État
et ses représentants ne souhaitaient pas
communiquer
il ne souhaite pas il ne souhaitait pas
informer les habitants ils ont été la
municipalité et bien sans charger pour
protester contre ce nouveau centre
d'accueil une quarantaine de personnes
majoritairement extérieure à la commune
monte un collectif dès lors une série de
manifestations de menaces physiques
verbales ou en ligne son proférées à
l'encontre de certains parents d'élèves
de la directrice de l'école ou encore du
maire lui-même à ses opposants se
joignent des groupuscules d'extrême
droite le maire décide d'alerter des
pouvoirs publics qui minimisent les
menaces le sous-préfet nous a tout
simplement dit mais les menaces vous
savez moi j'en ai tous les jours des
menaces
le commandant de gendarmerie
c'est pas grand chose ce sont simplement
des des menaces voilà c'est de
l'intimidation
ça ne sert à rien de déposer plainte
toute façon on ne fera rien c'est la
liberté d'expression yannique Mores et
ses équipes avoue s'être retrouvé
totalement démuni abandonné par les
services de l'État plus tard dans
l'après midi l'ancien maire de
Saint-Brévin assiste aux questions au
gouvernement depuis les tribunes
l'hémicycle du Sénat salut unanimement
son courage tenez bon face
à la
au-delà de l'hommage les sénateurs
veulent surtout des réponses et
interpelle à 5 reprises le gouvernement
sur son cas je n'aurai aucune difficulté
quand nous irons au terme de l'ensemble
de la lumière qui est nécessaire sur ce
qui s'est fait à Saint-Brevin à partager
avec vous et le constat et la
reconnaissance des dysfonctionnements
s'il y en a eu et je veux dire à Yannick
morrèze on le regardant que son exemple
a beaucoup d'égard il nous oblige entre
médiatisation et mobilisation des
parlementaires l'histoire de Yannick
Morez remonte désormais jusqu'au sommet
de l'État l'ancien maire sera reçu à
Matignon par la première ministre
Elisabeth borne en présence de Dominique
Faure ministre délégué aux Collectivités
Territoriales
pour en débattre j'accueille Philippe
babançoire bienvenue vous êtes sénateur
LR de la Manche et membre de la
commission des lois bienvenue à vous
Lucile le Schmitt bonsoir bienvenue dans
la réaction de la revue Esprit et
co-auteur de ce livre Emmanuel Macron a
contre-temps publié aux éditions Bayard
Stéphane Vernet bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous rédacteur en chef
délégué directeur de la rédaction de
Ouest-France à Paris et Mathieu
croissanto éditoris politique bonsoir
Mathieu Philippe de cette audition du
maire de Saint-Brévin
après tout ce qui lui est arrivé ce qui
est mal le plus frappé c'est la capacité
d'exposer les faits de la manière la
plus méthodique
et sans faire
de grands mots sans pathos inutiles sans
faire appel à l'émotion inutilement mais
d'une manière qui finalement est encore
plus efficace parce que son témoignage
est accablant et rejoint d'ailleurs des
choses que nous savons bien vous savez
en 2019 quand le maire de signes a été
tué dans l'exercice de ses fonctions par
des gens qui avaient déposé des
déchets des déchets sur le terrain privé
il avait été écrasé oui nous avons mis
en oeuvre une enquête grandeur nature
auprès tous les maires de France 4000
réponses déjà nous voulons savoir si
c'était un fait divers un accident ou un
phénomène c'était un phénomène nous en
avons eu cette époque la preuve nous
avons fait des propositions une partie
d'entre elles ont été reprise d'ailleurs
à notre initiative dans la loi quelques
mois plus tard des instructions très
fermes ont été donnés par la Garde des
Sceaux de l'époque madame beloubet au
procureur pour que les poursuites soient
diligentes rapidement et efficacement
des instructions étaient données au
préfet nous avons même relancé les
années suivantes et qu'est-ce qu'on
constate à travers ce que nous dit le
maire de Saint-Brevin on constate tout
simplement que les réactions
qui était opposé aux maires face aux
menaces et aux agressions avant 2019
sont les mêmes que celles qui la suivent
tout ça parce que on n'a pas réellement
dans les services de l'État suffisamment
pris conscience de la nécessité d'un
accompagnement de très grandes proximité
alors vous nous on y reviendrez bien
vous nous dites que il y avait les
outils pour finalement prendre en charge
et aider le maire de Saint-Brévin et que
ça n'a pas été fait alors disent pas des
horreurs du genre vous savez Monsieur le
Maire des menaces reçoit tous les jours
des menaces tous les jours et alors
disait la liberté d'expression etc comme
les autres n'importe quelle personne qui
nous écoute a le droit de devenir mère
mais n'a pas besoin d'avoir un doctorat
en droit connaître le droit pénal
connaître le droit administratif dans le
détail sinon il y a plus de démocratie
possible parce que personne ne peut plus
devenir mère alors justement Lucile
Schmidt pour vous que 17 agression de et
cette démission parce qu'il a confirmé
la volonté de démissionner le maire de
Saint-Brévin qu'est-ce que ça dit de
l'état de notre démocratie je trouve que
ça dit quelque chose déjà sur la
continuité de ce qu'on peut appeler
l'autorité publique c'est à dire qu'on
voit bien que là c'est une décision de
l'État en fait l'installation d'un acada
mais c'est une décision qui est
décentralisée c'est-à-dire que ça
s'installe dans un territoire et
là-dessus il y avait eu d'ailleurs un
vote du conseil municipal sur le
déplacement du CADA qui était là depuis
2016 en fait donc il fallait déplacer
bien donc c'est le déplacement du centre
d'accueil pour demander en asile qui
crée qui crée la police ce qui est
intéressant c'est que déjà en 2016 il y
avait eu un début de polémique parce que
installé un cadage ou de insister là
dessus c'est pas si simple parce qu'il y
a toujours une peur des migrants des
demandeurs d'asile et que donc en tout
cas il faut une grande continuité entre
ceux qui représentent l'autorité
publique à l'échelle centrale au niveau
national et évidemment une grande
solidarité entre ceux qui sont
dépositaires de l'autorité publique donc
en ce sens l'absence de solidarité ou
les réponses telles que elles ont été
décrites par le maire de Saint-Brévin
c'est d'abord c'est effrayant moi qui ai
fait pas mal tout droit sur la le
caractère flou l'absence justement vous
disiez il n'y a pas besoin d'être
spécialistes de droit pénal sauf que on
peut attendre d'un sous-préfet ou d'un
préfet que eux justement vous
accompagnent en termes d'expertise
juridique et vous disent voilà les
réponses qui s'offrent à vous si vous
êtes menacé et qu'on ne sous-estime pas
évidemment la menace qui existe parce
que vous êtes dépositaire de l'autorité
publique c'est pas parce que vous êtes
le citoyen X ou Y donc un premier point
c'est l'absence de solidarité un
deuxième point c'est l'absence
d'expertise offerte et le troisième
point c'est évidemment l'absence
d'explication conjointe c'est-à-dire que
laisser en première ligne un maire d'une
petite ville qui par ailleurs est une
petite ville balnéaire qui est une
petite ville où on compte sur une bonne
ambiance le tourisme etc donc tout ça
joue et donc cette question des
commerçants etc donc le laisser seul
pour expliciter une décision difficile
qui plus est lorsqu'il s'agit de se
mettre à proximité d'une école tout ça
montre une espèce de désincarnation de
la décision publique qui à mon avis est
grave et qui les conséquences étaient
presque écrites il fallait faire la
pédagogie ce que vous voulez d'ailleurs
vous on pourra s'appuyer sur l'une de
vos expériences puisque vous étiez en
cabinet mystérial à l'époque où il était
Lionel Jospin était à Matignon et vous
avez eu à gérer l'installation d'un d'un
cada en banlieue parisienne vous nous
racontant enfin en région parisienne
vous nous raconterez ça il y a peut-être
aussi Stéphane Vernet une question
autour de la banalisation de la de la
violence même dans la réaction que je
n'excuse pas mais des autorités
préférées il faut gendarmerie est-ce que
vous vous la ressentez notamment lors
des manifestations cette banalisation
alors oui moi je crois que c'est ce
qu'on soit qu'on vient d'assister et le
montre manifestement c'est à dire qu'il
y a un problème si vous voulez quand
vous avez un des gendarmes ou un
sous-préfet qui non mais moi je reçois
des menaces que vous disiez tout à
l'heure très bien où les gendarmes qui
disent non mais ça c'est de la liberté
d'expression on peut rien faire ça sert
à rien de porter plainte etc moi je
crois que ça s'inscrit aussi dans le
cadre d'une banalisation de la violence
dans notre société et qui touche même
les représentants de l'État et les
forces de l'ordre et je pense que c'est
très grave si vous voulez c'est-à-dire
que il faut aussi remettre les choses
dans un dans ce dans ce dans son
contexte
le maire de Saint-Brevin dit très bien
que lui en quelque part il a pas eu de
chance entre guillemets je m'explique il
donne le l'exemple d'un maire de l'Indre
qui a un cada qui s'installe chez lui en
disant bah lui mon mon confrère lui il
est très bien accompagné parce son
préfet son préfet il a des appels tous
les jours il est soutenu ce dont lui n'a
pas bénéficié c'est de ça dont il se
dont il se plaint à juste titre
peut-être et peut-être peut-être je me
trompe mais peut-être est-ce dû au fait
que ça ce qui se passe à Saint-Brevin
c'est la Loire-Atlantique on est proche
de Nantes de Notre-Dame-des-Landes que
c'est un secteur où il y a eu une
expérience de violence politique qui qui
ont été qui sont montés particulièrement
ces dernières années autour de la ZAD et
vous avez des pouvoirs publics et des
forces de l'ordre qui ont vécu des
choses par rapport aux manifestations
publiques ils sont peut-être pas du même
ordre que ça continue d'ailleurs depuis
pas sur toutes les manifestations mais à
Rennes notamment il y a eu pas mal de
violences post manifestations exactement
moi je pense qu'on est peut-être aussi
grâce à ce genre de choses où vous avez
envie dans un dans une société dans
lequel la parole est de plus en plus
débridée on sait malheureusement que les
mots précèdent les violences mais vous
avez aussi une accoutumance à la
violence de la part de la société en
général les gens se lâchent il faut le
dire les élus en manière générale sont
de manière générale sont en première
ligne par rapport à ces violences
verbales mais vous avez aussi toutes
sortes de dégradations physiques enfin
pardon matériel qu'on voit dans les dans
les manifestations qui ont qui ont monté
sans culpabilité ce qui les les
exactement vous avez un discours en fait
qui est en train de se diffuser dans
notre société qui consiste à dire oui
mais c'est symbolique ou ces matériels
c'est pas grave c'est pas c'est pas la
même chose que des violences faites aux
personnes alors qu'en fait il y a un
continuum dans la violence et dans la
violence politique elle peut prendre
différentes formes elles sont toutes
condamnables et moi je me demande si
dans ce qu'on a assisté dans ce qui est
arrivé au maire de Saint-Brévin il est
pas victime de ça aussi c'est à dire
l'accoutum des pouvoirs publics à une
violence qui monte et qui finalement qui
dit oui ce qui vous arrive et
problématique mais enfin bon en gros il
y a on s'en occupe mais il y a pire et
donc alors si grave si c'est grave bien
sûr vous avez posé les uns les autres
plusieurs thèmes qu'on va creuser
ensemble le premier effectivement c'est
la question de l'absence de de répondre
de de l'État et l'audition de Yannick
Morez aujourd'hui au Sénat elle était
édifiante aussi évidemment sur cette
question il raconte ses échanges avec
préfecture sous préfecture on l'écoute
le 7 avril j'ai écrit aussi préfets pour
lui demander en fait une protection
renforcée puisque sur les réseaux
sociaux commencer à circuler
une nouvelle manifestation qui était
prévue pour le 29 avril
et donc vu ce qui s'était passé j'avais
pas envie à nouveau voilà de subir des
des violences
le sous-préfet m'a répondu le 13 avril
en m'indiquant
qu'ils allaient faire une évaluation des
des risques sur ma personne voilà parce
que j'ai eu comme réponse et puis pas de
nouvelles donc il a fallu que je relance
en fait par mail le 25 avril
et le sous-préfet le 28 avril en fait
m'a répondu donc la veille de cette
manifestation voilà que l'évaluation des
risques était toujours en cours et elle
est toujours actuellement alors vous
l'avez bien compris ça c'est une toute
petite partie des singes après
l'incendie on est après le 22 mars donc
faut imaginer le climat général qui a
précédé à cette incendie vous nous avez
parlé Philippe Bas de la mort de
Jean-Mathieu Michel le maire de cygnes
et de la façon dont vous étiez président
de la commission des lois à l'époque
vous étiez emparé de cette question
qu'est-ce qui a été mis en place si on
rentre un peu dans le détail des des
dispositifs finalement assez assez
simple pour aider les maires dans une
configuration comme celle-là
je vais vous dire aussi ce qui n'a pas
été mis en place et commençons par ce
qui a été mis en place il y avait deux
aspects dans nos propositions on disait
le maire c'est le premier visage de
l'autorité dans la République en même
temps que leur présentant des citoyens
c'est un citoyen parmi les autres qui
est sorti durant et qui a accepté de
rendre service à sa communauté mais
toucher au maire c'est toucher
véritablement au fondement de la
démocratie et de l'autorité dans la
démocratie et par conséquent il faut une
protection spécifique des mères il faut
notamment que
dès la première menace dès la première
intimidation dès la première agression
au lieu de dire ah bah si la liberté
d'expression
il faut que vous ayez le cuire un peu
plus tanné vous êtes trop sensible etc
on prenne ça au sérieux et nous avions
premièrement demander que on ne mette
pas la charge du budget de la commune la
défense du maire que deuxièmement le
maire ne soit pas obligé d'aller
s'expliquer devant le conseil municipal
où il peut y avoir des mauvais
coupscheurs éventuellement ça pousse
produire heureusement c'est pas le cas
général pour obtenir que il y ait ce
qu'on appelle la protection juridique et
fonctionnelle et nous avons sur certains
points obtenus satisfaction que ça par
exemple c'est sur le premier c'est dans
la loi sur le premier point c'est passé
dans la loi sur le deuxième point ça
n'est pas passé dans la loi on peut
encore le faire et
nous avons demandé aussi donc à l'état
de de payer pour les maires en quelque
sorte puisque il s'agit de se défendre
lui-même l'État c'est pas d'un côté
l'état de l'autre côté les mers c'est un
ensemble c'est l'autorité dans la
République et par conséquent nous avons
demandé que l'État paie les frais de
d'avocat etc il l'a fait mais seulement
pour les communes de moins de 3500
habitants et puis il l'a pas fait pour
les élus des communautés de communes oui
on est un peu mesquin par voie ça c'est
quand même important d'émettre un signal
fort et puis nous avons dit et c'est là
que dans l'affaire de Saint-Brevin
l'état pêche le plus il y a des
défaillances et j'oserais même dire des
dysfonctionnements c'est précisément
parce que les maires nous avaient
signalé que la gendarmerie la
sous-préfecture et la justice
réagissaient en disant écoutez prenez-en
votre partie si vous avez voulu être
maire vous êtes exposé à séries si vous
le saviez bien bon et bien nous avons
entendu ça des centaines de fois dans
les réponses et c'est pour lutter contre
ça que nous avons exigé que des
consignes soient données au préfet ou
préfet et au procureur ces consignes ont
été donnés mais c'est comme une
bouteille à la mer on a l'impression que
personne ne s'est organisé or il s'agit
de mettre en place un véritable
accompagnement c'est-à-dire que au lieu
d'attendre que le maire se décide
éventuellement après avoir consulté un
avocat à porter plainte on le prenne par
la main pour qu'il puisse déposer sa
plainte et que le procureur comme le
président du tribunal face en sorte que
le jugement soit très rapide on peut pas
intervenir sur la justice mais que ce
jugement soit sévère à la mesure des
procédures à la mesure des faits ça n'a
pas été fait et puis il y a l'aspect
autorité
un maire quand il constate une
infraction bah c'est pas comme que
quelqu'un fait un excès de vitesse
devant un radar il faut qu'il engage
lui-même toute une procédure pour qu'on
puisse punir l'auteur de la fraction et
bien nous avons dit il faut que on
prévoit c'est du langage juridique des
amendes administratives que la personne
se voit infligée par la décision
d'autorité du maire pour qu'on sache
partout que quand on viole un arrêté
municipal et qu'on perturbe la
tranquillité publique la sanction va
tomber actuellement elle le taux de
renforcer l'autorité du maire alors là
je dois dire que le travail reste à
faire malgré le recommandation on l'a
bien compris Philippe je redonne la
parole à Yannick Mores dans ce dans
notre débat parce que il y a eu et pour
nous c'est peut-être l'élément le plus
important de une audition aujourd'hui il
va jusqu'à
accuser de mensonges le préfet de
Loire-Atlantique ça porte sur quoi ça
porte sur son dont vous nous parliez à
Lucy Schmitt l'accompagnement des élus
confrontés à l'installation ou au
déplacement d'un centre d'accueil pour
demandeur d'asile le préfet affirme
qu'il a organisé des réunions publiques
voilà ce que nous dit Yannick mares et
ce qui est désolant également quand vous
avez dû voir la communication du préfet
après après ma démission parce que je
m'attendais pas à ce que ça fasse des
remous des remous comme ça c'est cette
démission quand il dit qu'il a organisé
des réunions publiques
je parle de la part d'un préfet mentir
et frontément en public c'est quand même
important je sais pas il représente
l'État
il sait très bien qu'il a pas organisé
une réunion publique on a toutes les
preuves je suis lui demander la date il
pourra pas en fournir il en a pas fait
alors il y a deux aspects sur lesquels
on va revenir il y a l'aspect du
mensonge les accusations de Yannick
Maurice et puis il y a l'accompagnement
dans l'installation d'un cada peut-être
d'abord Stéphane Vernet je sais pas si
vous avez la réponse mais est-ce que le
préfet de Loire-Atlantique a répondu au
maire de Saint-Brevin est-ce qu'il se
défend si oui comment je crois que dans
le si je me souviens l'audition il dit
aussi que le préfet dit qu'il l'a appelé
plusieurs fois et en l'occurrence il m'a
appelé que deux fois une fois le jour de
l'incendie si je me souviens bien ou une
deuxième fois enfin
si vous voulez il y a une distorsion
entre ce que ce que ce que Yannick Morès
vit ressent en tant que victime parce
qu'il est victime dans cette histoire
c'est quand même extrêmement grave c'est
que c'est un médecin qui vivait sur
cette commune depuis 32 qui était maire
etc qui est obligé de partir enfin c'est
un drame humain terrible et lui vit
comme un décalage absolu le ce que le
manque de soutien qu'il a éprouvé mais
en même temps quand il est graine il dit
voilà j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone
j'ai eu un courrier j'ai eu un coup de
téléphone d'Olivier Véran j'ai eu un
courrier du président de la République
c'est par rapport au drame qui vit c'est
très insuffisant mais en face vous avez
une administration qui veut dire bah si
on a quand même réagi bah oui on a réagi
alors quand il parle de mensonge pour
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui veut dire
sur les réunions publiques c'est qu'en
fait qui dénonce depuis le début c'est
qui dit qu'il a été laissé seul face à
ses habitants à ses concitoyens pour
porter un projet qui lui était imposé
par l'État un projet imposé par l'État
et il a été seul pour le porter
c'est-à-dire que les réunions elles ont
eu lieu mais là où il y a un mensonge
c'est qu'elles n'ont pas été organisés
par la préfecture c'est lui qui se les
écoles Tiné c'est lui qui les a porté
qui les a incarnés et c'est contre lui
que la colère c'est cristallisée ce qui
s'est pas ce qui se passe pas
objectivement dans d'autres communes
c'est pour ça que je dis que vraiment il
y a
qui s'est passé c'est un cas d'école ce
qui se passe à à Saint-Brevin et je
pense j'espère que plus rien ne sera
pareil après ils font forcément il va y
avoir une réaction de l'État il y a un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui sont
qui sont prévus est-ce qu'ils seront à
la hauteur je sais pas il y aura des
annonces ce soir mais si vous voulez le
le
ce que montre cette histoire c'est que
c'est qu'il est pas possible de laisser
seul les élus de la République dans des
dans des dans des difficultés pareil oui
moi ce qui me frappe pour vous dire ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur la
banalisation de la violence c'est qu'on
se demande aussi qu'elle a été la
réaction de la classe politique en
général aujourd'hui on voit les
parlementaires se lever dans les
hémicycles pour témoigner de leur
solidarité on voit pas tous on voit des
je crois que c'est le parti socialiste
organise une marche blanche en
solidarité avec le maire de Saint-Brévin
et ils étaient où ces gens-là depuis six
mois c'est la mère de Nantes je veux
dire c'est pas très loin Saint-Brevin
est-ce qu'elle
je la désignais parce que sa mère
demande c'est pas une histoire de droit
toute gauche c'est où est-ce que la
classe politique elle-même ne sait pas
habituée à à ses formes justement de de
violence et au fond quand on touche un
maire vous le disait tout à l'heure
c'est le pilier de démocratie c'est le
pilier de la République c'est le c'est
le c'est un voilà un pilier est-ce qu'on
avait vous avez vu une manifestation
symbolique de la part tous les partis
politiques réunis un geste du président
de la République on a des ministres qui
se déplacent au moindre feu de poubelle
ou ou ou d'acte de délinquance et là on
a pas quelqu'un qui symboliquement et
dans l'ordre des choses c'est évidemment
l'exécutif mais aussi le Parlement le
pouvoir législatif qui dit ben on va
faire quelque chose parce que ça n'est
pas possible c'est vrai qu'il y avait
une émotion réelle après le décès du
maire de signes mais qu'on pouvait
encore considérer à l'époque comme un
fait divers je vous d'accord parce que
c'était c'était nous avons constaté
c'est ça n'était pas un phénomène ça il
y a eu quand même des maires qui ont été
agressés qui ont été victimes d'actes de
violence
tiers en l'espace de deux ans exactement
chiffre du ministre de l'Intérieur et
soleilf sont encore supérieurs chaque
année ça augmente et où est-ce que vous
avez vu une espèce de grande prise de
conscience politique pour le coup et je
ferme en honorable de la classe
médiatique aussi on va dire est-ce qu'il
y a pas un moment où on s'est dit c'est
juste insupportable et si je peux me
permettre je vous rejoindre ce qui me
frappe c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
un contexte étendu vous avez beaucoup de
manifestations et vous avez vous parlez
des politiques vous avez un certain
nombre de politiques qui sur les
plateaux vous explique que les
dépradations les dégradations et les
violences qui sont commises en
manifestation elles sont la faute du
gouvernement c'est la faute du président
de la République il n'a qu'à retiré sa
réforme des retraites moi je suis désolé
il y a il y a un moment il faudrait
quand même qu'on se redise
collectivement que les violences sont de
la responsabilité directe de ce qu'il
est comète voilà et que et que et elles
ne sont pas acceptables et pas
supportables et il y a quand même un
discours vous savez il y a une étude qui
est un sondage qui est sorti au mois de
au mois de mars au moment des au moment
des manifestations vous aviez plus
matière des fois sur l'acceptation des
violences par les physiques qui
comprenaient les violences et là je
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'on a un
problème de société dans la montée de
ces violences c'est-à-dire qu'elles sont
acceptées sur 10 les condames mais trois
sur 10 et qu'on comprenne alors et
parfois même alors je reprends ce que
nous disait uniquement dans ce dans le
dernier témoignage que je vous ai
proposé donc il parle du mensonge mais
il leur raconte aussi l'absence
d'accompagnement d'un installation enfin
du déplacement de ce centre d'accueil et
là je m'appuie sur votre expérience que
6 8 puisque je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
vous étiez conseillère au ministère
de la Solidarité et de l'emploi c'est ça
à l'époque où Lionel Jospin lui était à
Matignon on est bien d'accord
installation d'un cada dans les Yvelines
qu'est-ce que vous faites à ce moment-là
quel est votre rôle
d'abord je découvre que la décision
d'installation de ce cada avait été
prise par les services du ministère et
je suis d'abord touche contactée par la
mère du village dans lequel devait
s'installer ce cadavre et donc je
n'étais pas vraiment consciente ça avait
été géré administrativement et pas
politiquement je ne sais pas vraiment
consciente qu'il allait avoir 600
personnes qui allaient être installés
dans un cada donc dans un village les
Yvelines qui par ailleurs comprenait à
peu près 500 habitants donc la mère me
contacte et me dit c'est pas possible il
y a un problème de d'équilibre entre la
population et puis ce qui à l'époque est
quand même intéressant elle me dit par
ailleurs il y a aussi un problème social
c'est-à-dire que on a aussi beaucoup de
résidences secondaires donc il y avait
un mélange je dirais de la
proportionnalité mais il y avait aussi
l'inquiétude peut-être qu'il y a eu
aussi d'ailleurs à Saint-Brévin sur le
fait que ça allait déranger le modèle
économique de la commune et par ailleurs
l'État avait déjà installé un certain
nombre de familles polygame
abandon de les reloger autre part et
donc il y avait un précédent donc si
intéressant aussi par rapport à
Saint-Brévin c'est que là il y a une
sorte de précédent qui a été très bien
gérée c'est à dire qu'en 2016 on
installe ce cada et puis on veut aller
plus loin et dans le cas de cette
commune qui s'appelle émancé dans les
Yvelines ce qui est intéressant c'est
que moi je me dis bah il faut prendre le
taureau par l'école si je puis dire et
donc on va faire une réunion publique
avec l'ensemble des des personnes qui
souhaiteront y assister du village et
évidemment la mer était là j'étais là
pour représenter la ministre et puis il
y avait le directeur de la population
des migrations à l'époque donc on fait
cette réunion on fait de la pédagogie et
je sais pas si on va appeler ça de la
pédagogie mais je crois qu'on essaye en
tout cas d'expliquer qui sont les
demandeurs d'asile que ils ont souffert
des persécutions dans leur pays que ce
sont des personnes qui par ailleurs
s'engagent effectivement à respecter le
droit français et on dégonfle un certain
nombre de fantasmes qui sont exactement
les mêmes que ce qu'on voit 20 ans après
sur la violence c'est-à-dire que d'une
certaine manière on pratique la violence
vis-à-vis du maire au nom du fait que
peut-être on va subir de la violence et
puis il y avait toute une question
d'équilibre des populations et moi je me
rappelle d'une phrase qui revenait sans
cesse mais on peut pas les accueillir
parce qu'on ne pourra pas les intégrer
parce qu'on est trop différent donc on
adresse ce genre de choses et surtout
les élus les élus du coin je puis dire
était là donc d'ailleurs le sénateur
Gérard Larcher et
il m'a dit ce qu'il faut c'est restaurer
la proportionnalité et donc ce qu'on a
pris comme décision à l'issue de cette
réunion c'était bien l'idée qu'il
fallait sans doute un tiers par rapport
au nombre prévus un tiers de donc autour
de 200 personnes donc il y a des choses
qui sont de bon sens mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de prendre le risque
de se confronter à l'humain vous savez
dans cette histoire là il y a eu
beaucoup de réseaux sociaux il y a eu
beaucoup de virtualité il y a une vraie
anxiété par rapport à des fantasmes des
menaces qui sont au fond gonfler de
toute pièce par l'extrême droite et se
confronter c'est dégonfler la menace
c'est intéressant et je voudrais
vraiment vous entendre là-dessus Shiba
parce que s'il y a une action
défaillante de l'État finalement on
laisse le champ libre à l'extrême droite
sur des thématiques comme celle-là
vous savez je crois qu'il faut être
extrêmement vigilant tous les demandeurs
d'asile ne sont pas d'authentiques
réfugiés puisque 60% d'entre eux sont
déboutés
et que
la demande d'asile fait un bon qui
paraît largement motivé par le désir
d'utiliser cette procédure pour
s'introduire sur le territoire national
moi je ne souhaite pas faire
de notre débat un débat sur
l'immigration car de mon point de vue
quel que soit la discussion qu'on peut
avoir sur la manière dont on va réguler
l'entrée le séjour des étrangers en
France et maîtriser ce phénomène des
déboutés du droit d'asile quel que soit
les décisions qu'il faut prendre je
pense qu'il faut en prendre dans ce
domaine rien
ne peut excuser
ce déchaînement d'abord de menaces
d'intimidation de violence cette
expression de haine qui dépasse toutes
les bornes
de violence n'est pas facilité par
l'absence de d'explications
vous allez avoir le même type de
phénomène et s'il s'agit de créer un
centre d'enfouissement technique pour
les ordures ménagères vous allez aussi
avoir des gens qui vont prendre prétexte
de cela ce qui est
tout à fait préoccupant
presque je dirais angoissant dans l'état
de notre société c'est que tout est
hautement inflammable et que comme
l'état c'est loin on s'adresse de
préférence à celui qui est tout près et
que l'État au lieu de l'accompagner de
ce solidariser
se met sur le banc de touche et attend
que ça se passe mais c'est dès le
premier instant dès le premier message
d'intimidation qui ne relève pas
contrairement à ce qu'on a dit de la
liberté d'expression que l'État doit
être aux côtés du maire et donner un
coup d'arrêt à la violence parce que la
violence c'est comme vos adolescents
quand vous mettez pas de limite si on
n'a pas une forme de tolérance zéro dès
le premier acte alors on va au second et
on fait de l'assurance Mathieu et
ensuite l'État se met sur le banc de
touche par négligence ou par l'acheter
mais je crains fort que ce soit par
l'acheter pour ne pas s'exposer lui-même
il doit préférer dans ses circonstances
là laissez aller le bon soldat un maire
de Saint-Brévin au front au cas où il y
aurait des ennuis et quand il y en a au
lieu de l'aider on le laisse tomber et
ça je vais je trouve que c'est
extrêmement grave si on ne fait pas
respecter dans notre République
l'autorité à ce moment-là il n'y a plus
de confiance des citoyens à l'égard de
l'état de la réponse du gouvernement
dans un instant vous lit intervenir oui
je voulais juste dire une chose c'est
que je suis d'accord sur le fait que la
société est inflammable mais je crois
qu'il y a des sujets sur lesquels elle
est plus inflammable pour l'autre et je
pense que les questions migratoires sont
un sujet particulièrement inflammable et
que par ailleurs j'ai été assez marqué
par le fait que par exemple la
responsable association de parents
d'élèves a aussi reçu des menaces
lorsqu'on s'affichait favorable en tout
cas neutre par rapport à l'installation
de ce cada il y avait visiblement un
niveau de menace qui était extrêmement
fort et je crois que
l'instrumentalisation par le mouvement
d'Éric Zemmour a été particulièrement
importante sur les questions de déchets
ou ce genre de choses il y a aussi de la
réactivité mais je pense qu'elle a vous
savez c'est comme on parlait tout à
l'heure de Notre-Dame-des-Landes il y a
cette façon dont certains sujets ne sont
plus locaux en fait ce sont des sujets
nationaux et la virtualité les réseaux
sociaux en font une espèce de caisse de
résonance de l'ensemble de la violence
qui travaille aujourd'hui notre société
alors on va parler pardon je reprends la
main pour vraiment avancer parce que il
y a beaucoup de choses à dire sur la
réponse du gouvernement je propose la
Matthias 2 de nous rejoindre tout de
suite bonsoir Mathias puisque vous étiez
dans l'hémicycle cet après-midi avec une
séance donc de questions ou d'actualité
un question d'actualité gouvernement
particulièrement électrique absolument
Thomas c'était à la hauteur des attentes
après l'audition forte de ce mercredi
matin du maire de Saint Brévin par la
commission des Lois du Sénat la chambre
de référence des territoires à décider
donc de prendre le problème à bras le
corps une séance qui a donc largement
tourné autour de la question de la
violence contre les élus Yannick Morez
était d'ailleurs présent à la tribune et
il a été acclamé par tous les sénateurs
à la demande de Ronan Dantec du groupe
socialiste regardez
il est en tribune et c'est d'abord à ce
titre que nous lui rendons hommage il
tenait bon face à la haine de l'extrême
droite et des sbires Éric Zemmour
dans tel groupe écologistes on est bien
d'accord au-delà de l'hommage les
sénateurs attendaient des réponses voilà
c'est ça pas moi de six questions sur 16
et maintenant de six groupes différents
sont descendus des bancs de l'hémicycle
et la première d'entre elles venait du
président du groupe socialiste cette
fois Patrick kaner qui n'a pas mâché ses
mots
Saint-Brévin c'est aussi le signe d'une
résurgence des violences de l'extrême
droite depuis plusieurs semaines ces
actes de terrorisme intellectuel et
physique se sont multipliées pour
empêcher les mers qui le veulent de
prendre part à l'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile madame ma première ministre on
ne peut mettre sur un pied d'égalité
l'extrême droite et d'autres formes de
contestation l'extrême droite que ce
soit au sein de nos institutions ou dans
le cadre d'actions clandestine et
l'ennemi mortel de notre démocratie
l'État ne peut rester larmes aux pieds
face à ses menaces allez-vous engager ce
combat pour défendre les élus de la
République et qui dit président de
groupe dit réponse de la première
ministre Elisabeth borne avec une
affirmative l'État sera présent
les mers sont en première ligne sur le
terrain ils sont les premiers témoins de
la montée de la défiance dans notre
société nous devons les protéger nous
devons protéger tous les élus mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs il n'y a pas
de démocratie sans respect des élus pas
de démocratie sans sécurité pour les
élus avec vous tous avec le gouvernement
nous continuerons à agir je vous
remercie quelles avancées pourraient
être faites et bien la ministre déléguée
aux collectivités territoriales
Dominique fort a dû elle aussi répondre
à beaucoup de questions sur le sujet
elle a donné quelques pistes écoutez là
on va vous écouter et ça dans l'esprit
de ce qu'a dit Christophe Béchu tout à
l'heure de toujours s'améliorer oui on
va s'améliorer de ce que vous allez nous
dire Monsieur le Maire et de votre
perception de cette inaction perçue par
vous mais je voudrais juste citer un
point un point
ça s'appelle l'alarme élu c'est 3000
référents dans la gendarmerie et dans la
police nationale qui seront dès le début
de la semaine prochaine investis de une
extrême proximité ce sera des référents
violents aux élus ça a été décidé par le
début de la semaine par Gérald Darmanin
pour des annonces concrètes il faudra
maintenant attendre l'entretien entre
Yannick Morez maire de Saint-Brévin et
Elisabeth borde première ministre et
Dominique fort ce mercredi soir à mettre
merci beaucoup Mathias je me tourne
maintenant vers vous Mathieu pour
analyser cette cette réponse politique
du gouvernement à la hauteur pas à la
hauteur ben pas si ça se cantonne aux
réponses formulées jusqu'à présent par
Dominique Faure parce que cette crise
aura permis aux Français de découvrir
leur ministre des collectivités
territoriales au maire de Saint-Brévin
aussi visiblement dans la boîte mail n'a
pas été inondé de messages de solidarité
de sa ministre de tutelle
car elle celle qui multiplie depuis huit
jours les tweets de soutien et les
déclarations sur les violences contre
les élus n'avaient pas jugé bon
semblent-ils de lui passer ne serait-ce
qu'un coup de fil pendant qu'il était
dans la panade donc elle s'appelle
Dominique Faure c'est une élue locale
pourtant ancienne mère de
Saint-Orens-de-Gameville dans la
métropole toulousaine elle était
secrétaire d'État à la ruralité depuis
juillet dernier la réalité est hérité du
portefeuille des collectivités
territoriales lorsque sa prédécesseur
Caroline cailleux a démissionné et que
propose-t-elle pour répondre aux
désarroi des élèves quand on a entendu
ce qu'elle disait aujourd'hui et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est là que le bal bless à
part quelques larmes de crocodiles j'en
parlais tout à l'heure il n'y a pas
vraiment de quoi espérer un changement
rapide et radical le premier mesure
annoncé par la ministre c'est la mise en
place d'un centre d'analyse je la cite
un centre d'analyse et de lutte contre
les violences faites aux élus pour
cartographier les violences en
comprendre les origines pour pouvoir
agir dans le domaine de la prévention
j'ai envie de dire la belle affaire on
sait qu'il y a déjà un observatoire des
violences contre les élus qui a été
lancée par l'AMF dès 2020 et même qui
avait été pensé en 2019 après justement
le décès du maire de signe donc elle dit
qu'elle va donner à ce à ce centre un
rayonnement plus important en attente de
voir si il y aura des moyens pour
l'instant il y a pas grand chose second
axe l'alignement des peines punissant
les auteurs de violences contre les élus
sur celles contre les forces de l'ordre
alors ça c'est une idée ça fait que déjà
quelques temps qu'elle est dans les
tuyaux et on se demande un peu entre
nous pourquoi elle n'a toujours pas été
votée il y a eu des projets lois de
réforme de justice non il y a des
projets loin de réforme du Code pénal il
y a des choses qui ont été faites et
pourquoi on n'a pas trouvé la bonne idée
de la mettre alors si on la ressort
maintenant il serait s'agirait peut-être
de le faire et puis le dernier axe sur
un sujet qui lui tient à cœur dit-elle
un choc civique tenez-vous à votre
chaise quand même un choc civique très
tôt pour sensibiliser au plus jeune âge
les enfants pour leur faire prendre
conscience que le respect de la parole
de l'autre le respect de l'autorité et
la tolérance sont des valeurs qu'on a
envie de développer elle va le faire
avec Sarah el Airi mise à jeunesse et
papendaye l'éducation
immédiat et rapide et radicale qui
permettra aux élus de dormir sur leurs
doses merci beaucoup pour cette analyse
Mathieu croissant de Stéphane Vernet
qu'est-ce qu'on peut attendre il y a pas
manifestement de mesure très puissantes
dans dans les tuyaux parce que la
problématique elle est toute simple vous
pouvez pas mettre un gendarme ou un
policier derrière chaque mer ou chaque
élu local il y a 500 plus de 500000 donc
au lance pays on n'a pas les moyens donc
voilà après si vous voulez le système ce
qui a été évoqué dans l'hémicycle cette
histoire de référent 3000 référents
gendarmerie et police l'idée c'est celle
que je la comprends c'est de dire
tout élu victime de menaces ou de ou de
ou de violence aura quelqu'un qui qui
lui répondra en proximité de manière
immédiate ce qui a manqué au maire de
Saint-Brévin en fait toute la litanie
des gendarmes il y a besoin de la
protection
pas spécial pour les détection des élus
menacés si enfin voyez bien que dans le
cas d'espèces voilà un maire qui dit je
suis menacé il se passe quelque chose et
des mois il se passe rien les gendarmes
lui disent oh bah non mais mon pauvre
monsieur on peut rien faire c'est la
liberté d'expression enfin tout ce qu'on
s'est dit donc là si vous avez des gens
au sein de la des forces de l'ordre qui
sont fléchés pour avoir une écoute
mettre en place des choses concrètes
pour pour protéger comme ils peuvent les
élus qui sont l'objet qui font l'objet
de menaces je trouve que c'est je pense
que ça peut être un facteur
d'amélioration même si évidemment c'est
pas la panacée
dans ce que disait ce matin le maire de
Saint-Brevin pendant le division vous
avez un certain nombre de statistiques
qui existent sur les violences faites
aux élus et il disait lui-même je pense
qu'elles sont très très sous évaluées il
y a beaucoup qui subissent mais qui ne
disent rien
mais enfin il faut avoir du sens
pratique toutes ces bonnes paroles
structure nationale qui vont mettre le
projecteur sur les phénomènes qu'on
connaît très bien depuis 2019 nous les
premiers on a fait cette enquête
grandeur nature c'était quand même des
données fiables importantes non on n'a
pas besoin de tout ça on n'a pas besoin
de bonne parole quand on reçoit un coup
de fil du préfet c'est pas pour entendre
des douceurs c'est pour l'action et en
réalité si le gendarme ne s'est pas
évalué lui-même les chances d'obtenir
une une condamnation dans une affaire
comme celle-ci et bien de toute façon
nous demandons nous que le préfet ou le
sous-préfet prennent par la main le
maire et que il y a une évaluation avec
le procureur de sorte immédiatement on
puisse déposer la plainte on ne demande
pas de former des gendarmes spécialisés
on demande que partout en France quand
survient de telle menaces ou agressions
la prise en charge se fasse par les
services de l'État et si le bon gendarme
n'est pas à Saint-Brevin-les-Pins on en
trouvera quand même bien un dans le
département de la Loire-Atlantique
les gendarmes des favorables
non ça ne veut pas dissuader la violence
mais ça va permettre de punir ce qui
commettent ces actes et je crois que à
la longue le choc que ça provoquera de
se dire il faut protéger autant que les
pompiers les gendarmes et les policiers
nos mères ça c'est une vraiment mesure
qui est alors très forte je le crois il
nous reste un peu un peu plus de 3
minutes dans ce débat ça a fini trop
vite mais il y a un dernier thème
démissionnant et je rappelle que sa
démission n'est toujours pas acceptée en
démissionnant je vais partir en bateau
de toute façon je pars on l'accepte pas
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il
a fallu qu'il dise qu'il démissionnait
pour que d'une certaine manière pour
parler de l'arme de crocodile tout le
monde lui adresse des tweets qu'il
apprenne par le journal qu'il a être
reçue par la première ministre donc il y
a un côté je parlais de virtualité je
pense que là il y a une réalité de ce
qui fait qui donne une force très
concrète à ce qu'il dit et qui va
obliger par exemple à regarder combien
gagne un maire lorsqu'il est dans une
petite commune ce à quoi il renonce en
terme professionnel ce que subit sa
famille vous savez c'est aussi ne jamais
être tranquille moi j'ai été qu'on lui
donne pour exercer ses compétences au
service de la population qui ne cesse de
se réduire d'être encadré par des normes
supplémentaires tandis que les
ressources n'ont cessé de diminuer avec
la suppression des impôts locaux comme
la taxe d'habitation
il y a la question des moyens mais il y
a aussi un élément psychologique je
trouve qu'il a très bien mis en avant
parce que au fond lorsque vous êtes élu
et particulièrement lorsque vous êtes
maire vous n'êtes jamais tranquille vous
n'êtes jamais auprès de votre famille et
si en plus ne jamais être tranquille ça
permet de faire de merveilleuses
rencontres et de sentir le bien public
c'est parfait mais si ça consiste à être
agressé quel est l'intérêt je crois
qu'il la merveilleusement dit encore une
fois c'est une sorte de lanceur d'alerte
à vous de la conclusion Stéphane Vernet
sur ce ras-le-bol des mers de plus en
plus agressé pourquoi ils sont agressés
il y a plusieurs raisons et plusieurs
raisons mais une des principales en fait
si vous voulez c'est la frustration
c'est-à-dire que on ne supporte plus que
quelqu'un nous dise non là je parle de
manière collective vous allez vous avez
plein d'administrés on leur refuse
interdit de construire ils veulent avoir
une place de parking réservé devant
juste devant chez eux le maire leur dit
non etc il y a pendant longtemps si vous
voulez vous preniez ça sur vous en dira
je voterai pas pour lui la prochaine
fois et puis dans la montée des
phénomènes c'est devenu on est passé à
l'insulte
et aujourd'hui on passe à des on passe à
la violence physique la plupart la
plupart des des agressions verbales ou
des violences elles sont liées à cette
espèce de refus le maire de Saint-Brevin
le disait dans son audition il disait
bon courage pour le zan une mesure qui
va faire qu'en fait vous avez un certain
nombre de terrain qui ne seront plus
constructibles et il dit mais qui va
devoir annoncer aux gens que le terrain
qu'ils ont acheté pourront pas ils
pourront pas y mettre une maison pour
leurs enfants etc et vous croyez que ça
a bien se passer il a raison c'est à
dire que vous avez vous les élus les
maires c'est vraiment les élus de
première proximité sera portée
d'engueulade comme dit Gérard Larcher
mais en fait ils sont ils sont ils sont
seuls ils incarnent une autorité qui est
de plus en plus contestée et qui
aujourd'hui est de plus en plus contesté
par la violence et il faut trouver un
moyen d'endiguer ça parce que
effectivement ça va pas bien se passer
on aura plus de candidats ou des gens
qui vont qui vont diminuer démissionner
en masse comme ça se passe aujourd'hui
en cours de mandat très vite Philippe
Bas vous le craignez ça le le manque de
candidat au prochain je ne sais pas
n'est pas certain bon il y a peut-être
ça que ça sert c'est quand même une
situation très particulière et un cas
d'école mais ça vient s'ajouter à une
forme de marasme une forme parfois de
sentiments d'impuissance des mères il
faut les conforter absolument et c'est
pas seulement le problème de leur
sécurité je crois que ça a été très bien
dit je n'y reviens pas c'est le problème
aussi de leur capacité d'action au
service de la communauté mais très vite
je rencontre beaucoup de mer ils sont
quand même dans l'ensemble heureux de ce
qu'ils font c'est une chance formidable
dans une vie de femme d'homme de pouvoir
se mettre au service des eaux allez on
va terminer sur une autre positive et
c'est bien merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat je rappelle
Lucille Schmitt le titre de votre livre
Emmanuel Macron à contretemps qui est
publié aux éditions Bayard